welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jonathan Watson an assistant
professor of sociology and international
affairs at Yale University professor
Watson is a comparative historical
sociologist with teaching and research
interests in north african society and
politics he works on the areas of state
formation colonialism and empire
ethnicity and nationalism urban and
rural contentious politics and Islamic
social movements today we'll talk with
Professor Woodson about his new book
constructing Morocco colonial state
building and the struggle to define the
nation welcome professor Watson Thank
You Allen let's begin with an overview
of your book and the question at its
foundation okay this book looks at a big
question in in examining how nations are
formed how nations are defined and I'm
taking a very specific case I look at
Morocco to analyze how this plays out in
an empirical sense and the critical
question that I'm interested in is in
its you know in the colonial period in
Morocco which was between 1912 and 1956
you had an outside power European
actually the French and the Spanish that
come in to Morocco ostensibly to do
state building to do state formation and
what I do is look at this period and
analyze these two processes state
formation or state building on the one
side and then nation building or nation
formation on the other and what I'm
interested in is the specific reasons
for how and why Moroccan national
identity was defined the way that it was
which in the end and not independence in
1956 you have a very strong definition
of an Arab identity Muslim identity and
then the critical importance of the king
as a figurehead that unifies the nation
okay and what was the inspiration for
writing the book this book the origins
of this go back to a time when I was
when I first was working in Morocco
several years ago when you drive around
the country you see
from the north to the south of the
country on hills or mountain sides three
words that are painted on to the rock so
you can see from the highway at the top
you have Allah God and then at the
bottom you have a lot on the nation and
L Melek the king and you have this
triptych these three words God nation
and king that basically define what
Moroccan national identity or at least
the official version of that is and when
I with this project what is interested
in is going back into the story the
genealogy of how this particular
definition of Moroccan identity came to
be okay I know you're in the final
stages of actually writing the book but
tell us a little bit about the
methodology how are you doing the
research well to uncover the way that
the story came came about and basically
there's an assumption here that this is
a process rather than a given moroccan
identity is not something that just
exists but that it's something has
historically evolved and has been
constructed over time and what i was
interested in is getting into the the
various players that were involved in
that story and by examining the colonial
period i basically looked at examining
the from on the state building side the
french colonial administration then you
have an urban nationalist movement that
gets mobilized in the 1930s the the king
who plays an important role and then i
was really interested in several other
groups that are the non elites but that
played an important role that has not
been the story on their side has not
been told as extensively and these were
the tribal groups that were outside of
the the urban areas which primarily
berber-speaking the country had a very
sizable Jewish minority and then the
other kind of underlying a group that
doesn't get a lot of coverage in the
history of this period are women and all
the various roles that they played and
so in the methodology that I pursued was
to go back into colonial archives to
identify other kind of non-traditional
types of sources to get some of these
voices particularly the tribal Berber
side and women to bring their
perspective on the process of nation
formation that went on during the
colonial periods
okay let's talk a little bit more
specifically about each of those groups
the women the Berbers and the Jews how
did each define help to define Moroccan
identity during this period the that
process actually works out in tandem
with that the other major players that
are involved which and this is the story
that usually gets told is the way that
the colonial administration sought to
prevent the unification of a Moroccan
resistance and then used policies to
divide the Moroccan society or to
reinforce divisions that they perceive
that were there and what they actually
tried to do was to use ethnicity to try
to divide between Arab and Berber to use
religion to divide between Jews and
Muslims and then use gender also there's
a fundamental division that was in place
in terms of education you have voice in
one school girls in another of course
law was very much gender based in which
men have different rights than women do
and so to start with the Berbers this is
these populations which lived in more
inaccessible areas in the mountains for
instance that are off of the coast and
in the deserts they were actually the
the most intractable groups that the
French had the most difficulty in
Spanish also in pacifying or militarily
conquering these areas and so you
actually have several decades it's not
until the mid 1930s that this process of
pacification is completed and the the
Berber is that resistance and then the
kind of subsequent story where they get
incorporated into the colonial army it
is a whole part of Moroccan history that
has not been well chronicled and
actually a really critical element in in
how both the nationalists and the French
were trying to control definitions of
the nation and on the French side
they're basically trying to say that the
Arabs and the Berbers were completely
distinct that the Berbers weren't really
Muslim and on the other side the Arabs
were basically trying to say the
opposite that there was a fundamental
unity there of Arabs and Muslims so to
examine that the Berber perspective what
I did is look at a tree an archive of
poetry that was actually gathered during
that time period which is really a
unique way to get a voice
from a population that didn't have
written sources and in this oral of
medium you get to hear their
perspectives on on the conquest on this
dilemma of this almost apocalyptic sense
of impending doom as the French are
conquering the country and you actually
get to hear women and men so it was
fascinating that's a fascinating aspect
that I was able to uncover in the study
so I'm sure this is actually oral people
recited the poetry - or is it it's not
written this so in its original
incarnation these were poems that were
were chanted in a public ceremony in you
know in a song but during the period of
the colonial period as the past this
military conquest was happening there
was a French officer whose hobby was to
gather all of this poetry he sat down
and transcribed that and then he had
multiple moroccan assistants
interlocutors that went out into these
areas and gathered this from basically
from the north of the country to the
south and so it provides us really
amazing insight into how these group you
know insurgent groups what the
resistance fighters you know depending
on your perspective their side to the
story what conclusions do you reach in
the book I know it's not finished yet
but right whether in terms of the the
basic question and this is a you know
relevant question in light of what's
happening in the American involvement in
Iraq for instance or in Afghanistan in
these these places where you there's a
lot of talk about failed States or you
know how do you actually go about state
formation nation formation you know to
go back into this period where you had a
somewhat similar circumstance with an
outside power that's interested in these
processes and in some ways controlling
them I think one of the conclusions one
of the basic conclusions is that that
political context of this outside power
coming in does really impact the the
process of identity formation but impact
us in ways that are really difficult to
to pre-ordained or to actually control
and so like for in the Moroccan case you
actually had a very interactive
processes where the inputs from the
colonial regime from an urban
nationalist group from a traditional
government the Sultan the King that they
kept in place and then from these other
outlier groups all of this goes into a
very complex process that works over
time
and in the other major conclusion is
that that process doesn't stop at a
given point that this is a continuing
process okay and what was the most
surprising thing you found in doing the
research for the book the the I think
that stuff that was most fascinated by
and that was most surprising was to get
into the story that I was talking about
before of this berber side to Morocco's
colonial history which the you know the
official nationalist versions that come
out after independence definitely
incorporate these and basically label
them as a part of a teleological
seamless process of the Moroccan nation
emerging but what you see what in
getting into that Pro tree itself you
see lots of competing voices trying to
understand what is happening in in
processing as a communal level at this
greater level beyond a tribal
identification in some sense it's kind
of a pre national sense of Moroccan
identity but in a very different angle
than the urban Arab nationalist were
were defining that and what's
interesting there is kind of the
intimacy of some of the poetry that
deals with this conquest at the level of
their families being being killed at the
same time that they're also processing
this at a very corporate level thanks
very much for being here with us today
and sharing some of your research thank
you you're welcome
for more information about professor
watson and his work please visit our
website at yale.edu backslash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
whitney and betty macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale